should we start with jeans t-shirts tank
tops like there's too much in here I
don't even know okay so I'm paired with
jasmine and I'm IRA member telling
people that I was really intimidated
when I found out that I was paired with
her because she dressed so fly and so
fresh honestly feel like I'm all over
the place like some days I'll have on a
snapback and like no makeup and a
windbreaker and then today I'm in like
eyeliner and lipstick so I really feel
like I'm all over the place
one of my friends told me that I dressed
like a lesbian and I was like that's
pretty dope I'll take it I don't know
she's very like simple
she doesn't like go over-the-top or
anything like that on days when I'm
feeling lazy or tired
I might forego anything super stylish
and I'll just throw in like a t-shirt a
hat and a hoodie I think I'm gonna wing
it just because I kind of feel like
that's the spirit of Jasmine's wardrobe
anyways in which like it's very like
free it's very like unhinged she keeps
it really you know casual Q not really
that many accessories so I'm you know
I'm gonna jazz that up a little bit we
are here at iguanas and I'm gonna make
her look hot ooh this is cute
that's moppet the fact that I'm
plus-size will be interesting too
because I feel like a lot of people
don't consider that especially because
he's a smaller guy he's just they're so
tiny though I don't think I don't think
these will work well maybe this one no I
went ugly do you think we should get a
little jacket this is actually cute you
should
Schuyler mr. hat as long as she wears
like the right accessories with it I
think she could do this the only
question is if it's her size Nik has
done my makeup before and he like went
for like a pretty like intense look
which makes me wonder whether he'll give
me something that is very like vibrant
or something that like draws a lot of
attention to it how cute are these with
this jacket literally everything I see
I'm like how she probably has this
already all of the fashionistas in the
world are probably gonna be like what
the hell are you doing who eat a minute
here do you think that would be a little
no I'm not gonna do her like that I'm
pretty confident that I will be able to
take something that she likes I think I
was I'm able to knock out the torso and
pants with one go with this with this
jumpsuit and so because I know that she
can rock a jumpsuit yeah I could see her
rocking something like that at the very
least I got her a nice army jacket I
think we got it
she's ready to go out and just have fun
with the girls just live her life and
feel sex okay you're ready to try this
on mmm I'm not come on out your shoes
are too big oh ha ha ha
who thought I'd come in here look in
like trash and I come out looking like
this glass the glasses with your hair
hey Greg
so good honey lesbian wear this I
usually like the right size I guess I
like the jacket yeah I love the gold
chain seriously design up my game
definitely and this was adorable um it
got over my ass I was freaking out a lot
over the jumpsuit but I'm at least
thankful that she was very understanding
forgiving that it didn't quite fit
shopping one for women and two like for
a plus-size woman is not easy at all
at the very least I'm glad that she
likes all the other stuff and I gave her
I thought I did an amazing job she
looked so good
she's already fabulous but when you
throw on that mean jacket and those
pumps oh she's so hot I think Nick
picked out a really nice outfit I feel
like I've just really recently started
like figuring out what my style is and
once have a clothes I like to wear and I
think Nick just added like a nice little
bit of pizzazz